حسنًا ، أريد إحضار وزير الخارجية
الأردني أيمن سفاري ، ينضم إلي الآن
من عاصمة ولاية فيرمونت ،
وزير الخارجية المسؤول عن
العنف الذي شهدناه في القدس
مؤخرًا خاصة حول المسجد الأقصى ،
مساء الخير أه فيكي أه بشكل أساسي  ما
أراده الأردن من كل شيء أن
يتأكد من احترام الوضع أه القانوني والتاريخي
الراهن الحرام أه
حتى نحافظ على الهدوء الذي
عمل الجميع بجهد كبير على تجنب العنف
ومن ثم التحرك نحو
أفق سياسي يجلب
و  وإلى الصراع الفلسطيني الإسرائيلي
حتى ينال الجميع
السلام الصحيح للجميع
أه ما حدث في الأقصى بالطبع
انعكاس للتوتر المستمر أه
الذي ظل أه يتصاعد هناك منذ
أسابيع قبل أه أه أحداث
الجمعة الماضية حتى قبل
بداية شهر رمضان أه رأيتم أه
النشاط المكثف يقود بشكل جيد
والجهد الذي بذله الأردن للتأكد من
أننا نخفف من حدة الآفة  بخلاف أه أه
بالأساس من حيث ما حدث
العام الماضي فأنت لا تجيب على
السؤال السؤال هو من يقع اللوم على هذا
العنف سيدي مع احترام
من يقع اللوم في البداية أه حقيقة
أنه لا يوجد أفق سياسي
حقيقة أن الوضع الراهن هو  عدم
احترام حقيقة أننا رأينا الكثير
من الإجراءات التصعيدية من
قبل المستوطنين ومن قبل أه المتطرفين
وحقيقة دخول القوات الإسرائيلية في أه
أه اقتحمت أه الأفزة
الأسبوع الماضي أه لا نبحث عن أه هنا
في  شروط ما يحدث الآن ما
نريد فعله هو ما فعلناه دائمًا هو
كيف نتطلع إلى الأمام كيف
نتجاوز الأزمة الحالية احتواء
التوتر ضمان احترام الوضع
الراهن في الحرم والمضي قدمًا.
تجاه أه الحفاظ على
الوقت لتحقيق السلام اتهمت إسرائيل
الأردن بتشجيع الفلسطينيين
الذين تقول إنهم يرتكبون أعمال عنف
في القدس خلال اليومين الماضيين
ردك لم أسمع أي إسرائيلي  رسميًا ، أطلق
هذا الاتهام ، لقد سمعنا الكثير من
التقارير بشكل أساسي ، ما أود قوله هو
أن سجل الأردن من
الواضح أن تاريخ الأردن واضح أننا نشجع دائمًا على الحوار
ونشجع دائمًا على التفاوض دائمًا ،
ونشجع الوسائل السلمية
لتسوية النزاع في نفس الوقت الذي كنا فيه
دائمًا  من الواضح جدًا للإسرائيليين وللجميع أن الوضع
الراهن للمسجد الأقصى للحرام
يجب احترامه ، وأن انتهاك هذا الوضع
الراهن سيؤدي إلى انفجار
نظرًا
لقدسية الحرام والتوتر العام
الذي
هو  إلى حد كبير نتيجة الفشل أه
للمضي قدمًا نحو
الأفق السياسي لذا سأقول
إننا واضحون جدًا كأردن أه
عملنا دائمًا من أجل السلام
سنستمر في العمل من أجل السلام
وما شجعناه  على الإسرائيليين القيام به
هو احترام الوضع الراهن وكل
محادثاتنا مع
الفلسطينيين كانت موجهة للعمل
معًا للحفاظ على السلام
والتأكد من
أننا نحافظ على  الهدوء الذي تحدث به زميلي
كريستيان ألمان بول
حصريًا مع رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي نفتالي
بينيت في وقت سابق ، أريدك فقط
أن تستمع إلى هذا التبادل
عندما يرى العالم وعندما
يرى الفلسطينيون وعندما ترى منطقتك
جنودًا إسرائيليين داخل ذلك
المسجد ،
فإنها تخلق الكثير.  من التوتر ، الكثير من
القلق ، لماذا تسمح للجنود
الإسرائيليين بالذهاب إلى هذا المسجد ،
حسنًا أيها المسيحي ، هناك تذهب مرة أخرى
لتبدأ القصة في المنتصف ،
لكن الحقيقة الفعلية هي أنه في يوم الجمعة الماضي
في حوالي الساعة الخامسة صباحًا ،
دخل ما يقرب من 300 مثيري شغب فلسطيني
المعبد  جبل مسجد
بالمتفجرات بالحجارة بدأوا في
تدنيس مسجدهم وحرقوا
رشق الحجارة ومنع حوالي 80
ألف مسلم من الذهاب للصلاة.
اضطررت إلى إرسال رجال شرطة لإبعاد
مثيري الشغب ، وقد نجح بالفعل 80 ألف
مسلم ذهب في وقت لاحق  للصلاة بسلام
حتى تعرف أنه عند مواجهة العنف ،
عليك أن تتصرف بصرامة
وزير الخارجية ، أريد فقط أن
أضغط عليك قليلاً فيما
كنا نناقشه للتو من قبل ردًا
على ما سمعته للتو هناك
ولا يوجد الأردن  متهم
بتشجيع الفلسطينيين أم لارتكاب
أعمال عنف نشطة من قبل مشرع إسرائيلي أم
أه ، لكن
رد الأردنيين على
ما يجري يعتبر نشاطًا
مشجعًا من
قبل
الفلسطينيين داخل المجمع
هل هذا منطقي
أنا فقط  تريد أن تحصل على ردك على
ذلك تحديدًا لا ، أليس كذلك ،
لا معنى له ، بيكي أه أه ما
فعله الأردن هو نفس الموقف الذي اتخذه
تاريخيًا على مدى العقود التي استغرقها العام الماضي ،
فقد استغرق الأمر هذا العام أن يكون الوضع
الراهن هو التاريخي  يجب احترام الوضع القانوني الراهن
للحرم ، وأن
حرية الصلاة للمسلمين في الحرم يجب
أن تُحترم القيود وأن الوصول
إلى الحرم يجب أن يتم رفعه
وهذا ما فعله الأردن وهذا هو و
وما فعله الأردن أيضا هو حث
الجميع أه على التأكد من أننا أه
التخفيف من أه أي اندلاع
عنف أه بداية القصة
أه بيكي أن
لدينا صراع
مستمر في التهرب من حل
عملنا من
أجله  الأشهر القليلة الماضية حتى قبل أه
محاولة خلق أفق سياسي من
شأنه أن يخاطب قضية
أن هناك احتلال لا يوجد
أفق لحلها يجب أن نتحرك
نحو أه إنهاء كل التوترات
والتقدم نحو الدولتين  المحلول